[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing Dumbledore
The Potters and the fabled invisibility
cloak specifically we're going to be
taking a look at the events of the time
period surrounding the Potter's murder
and why on Earth Dumbledore chose to
borrow an item of such great protection
when the Potter family's lives were in
imminent danger if the cloak is so
powerful that even death can't find you
wouldn't it be most useful in the hands
of people who are hiding from the most
powerful dark wizard to have ever lived
let's dive in the invisibility cloak is
a powerful magical artifact that once
belonged to ignotus pevl the youngest
brother from The Tale of Three Brothers
a story outlining the origin of each
Deathly Hallow the plot surrounds the
three wizard brothers and their ability
to cheat death for a short period of
time after conquering death a
personification of death under the guise
of congratulating them Awards them with
three gifts the Elder Wand the
resurrection Stone and the invisibility
cloak long story short each brother
chose one of the gifts that death had
presented them ignotus the youngest
chose the invisibility cloak all three
of these objects are massively
instrumental in the Harry Potter story
and while the Elder Wand is a huge plot
driver the invisibility cloak definitely
ended up being the most useful hallow
for Harry which is interesting because
it was indirectly handed down to him by
his father after James's death it was
kept safe until Harry was old enough to
appreciate it at which point Dumbledore
anonymously gifted the cloak to Harry in
the philosopher stone but why did
Dumbledore have this Potter family
artifact around the time that Lord
Voldemort was hunting The Potters the
cloak of invisibility came to the
attention of Dumbledore when James
showed it to him and after a cursory
inspection of the cloak Dumbledore ended
up asking to borrow the cloak from James
in order to study it but this was a bit
of a weird request Dumbledore had the
power to cast the disillusionment charm
a spell capable of rendering him
invisible allowing him to perfectly
blend in with his surroundings what use
could he have possibly had with the
invisibility cloak and of all all of the
times to borrow it this seems like the
most
inappropriate the most obvious and safe
answer is that Dumbledore wanted to
study the cloak because it's one of the
three Deathly Hallows in his youth
Dumbledore became infatuated with the
idea of uniting the three Hallows and
though he had long since abandoned that
path he maintained an interest in these
powerful magical artifacts being a
highly knowledgeable and curious wizard
it's possible that he may have wanted to
explore the cloaks capabilities and
better understand its
Origins furthermore it's likely that
Dumbledore did not feel that James poter
needed the invisibility cloak for
protection against Lord Voldemort as the
family was already safeguarded by the
fidelus charm a powerful enchantment
that concealed the location of the
Potter family from
Voldemort but of course we all know how
well the Fidel's charm worked out for
them after being betrayed by their
Secret Keeper Peter pettigru all of the
Potters but Harry were killed killed
after Voldemort entered their Cottage in
godric's Hollow with James killed the
cloak was left in Dumbledore's
possession he later explains the origins
of the cloak to Harry the cloak as you
know now traveled down Through the Ages
father to son mother to daughter right
down to ignotus his last living
descendant who was born as ignotus was
in the village of godric's hollow
Dumbledore smiled at Harry me you you
have guessed I know why the cloak was in
my possession on the night your parents
died James had showed it to me just a
few days previously but there's
something that feels off about all of
this the poters were in immense danger
they had the most dangerous dark wizard
of all time specifically targeting them
and they went to Extreme Measures to
stay hidden en listing the help of the
fidelus charm how could dumbledor had
such a major oversight in borrowing the
cloak from James how could he have been
so obtuse Dumbledore is a calculated
powerful Wise Old wizard that's
typically steps ahead of everyone
something doesn't sit right with me here
hold on to your broomsticks because I've
got a scandalous Theory I think that
Dumbledore may have deliberately
borrowed the cloak with the intention of
leaving the Potter family more
vulnerable to Lord Voldemort hear me out
I think that Dumbledore's actions in
this scenario spell out a strategic and
calculated decision rather than mere
curiosity
I think the Dumbledore who had deep
knowledge of the prophecy regarding
Harry Potter and Voldemort recognized
the potential significance of the cloak
in the upcoming Conflict by borrowing
the cloak it's possible that he sought
to manipulate the course of events to
align with his vision of defeating
Voldemort and one possible motivation
behind this theory is Dumbledore's
belief in the concept of the greater
good Dumbledore was aware of this
prophecy and its importance as well as
the fact that Voldemort was seeking to
destroy the Potter family in order to
eliminate the one who could defeat him
it's possible that Dumbledore saw
borrowing the invisibility cloak as a
calculated move in fulfilling the
prophecy and ultimately defeating
Voldemort he may have reasoned that
sacrificing the immediate protection
offered by the invisibility cloak would
ultimately lead to a more advantageous
outcome such as enabling Harry to
fulfill his role in the prophecy and
ultimately defeat Voldemort this Theory
also challenges the notion that
Dumbledore saw no need for the
invisibility cloak due to the fidelus
charm instead it suggests that he
intentionally gambled with the safety of
the Potter family placing greater
importance on the overall outcome of the
battle against
Voldemort Dumbledore's manipulation of
events throughout the series suggests
time and time again that he was willing
to take risks for the sake of the
greater good he orchestrated the events
leading up to the Battle of Hogwarts
even knowingly placing Harry In Harm's
Way to ultimately defeat Voldemort
borrowing the invisibility cloak would
not be out of character for Dumbledore
as it aligned with its willingness to
make difficult decisions and sacrifices
in service of the larger goal but I know
that there are some fans out there who
can't possibly rationalize or come to
terms with the idea that dumore may be
evil so I'll also introduce some
counterpoints to this Theory the main
counterargument is just what the story
tells us that Dumbledore made the the
decision to borrow the invisibility
cloak out of pure curiosity I mentioned
earlier that there's no way Dumbledore
could have been so obtuse as to borrow
the cloak without consideration for the
repercussions of his actions but there
may be a hole in that assertion we see
when it comes to Deathly Hallows
Dumbledore can be a bit of a blustering
buffoon ever since his youth Dumbledore
had a long standing and dangerous
obsession with the three magical
artifacts and it's entirely possible
that the dangling carrot that was the
opportunity to inspect the invisibility
cloak may have caused him to act out of
character Dumbledore's dangerous
obsession with the three Deathly Hallows
can be attributed to several factors
including his thirst for knowledge his
desire for power and his fascination
with the mysteries of life and death
firstly Dumbledore was known for his
insatiable thirst for knowledge and
understanding he was a highly
intelligent wizard who delved deep into
the Realms of magic history and ancient
artifacts
the Deathly Hallows with their immense
power and significance would undoubtedly
have piqued Dumbledore's intellectual
curiosity he would have been drawn to
their Legends and the potential
understanding they could provide about
the nature of magic itself secondly
Dumbledore's desire for power cannot be
overlooked while he was primarily driven
by desire to protect and bring about
good there were instances where his
hunger for power and influence was
revealed the Deathly Hallows especially
the Elder W represented the ultimate
power in The Wizarding World possessing
all three Hallows would have granted
Dumbledore an unprecedented level of
control and Authority which may have
enticed him Dumbledore has a good line
on this it is a curious thing but
perhaps those who are best suited to
power are those who have never sought it
furthermore Dumbledore had a deep
fascination with life and death and
sought to unlock their Mysteries the
Deathly Hallow symbolized the Mastery of
a death
and dumble Wall's exploration of this
theme was evident in his research and
encounters with various magical
artifacts throughout his life the
Hallows represented a way for Dumbledore
to understand and potentially even
conquer death which may have fueled his
obsession while dumor ultimately used
his knowledge and power for the greater
good his dangerous obsession with the
Deathly Hallows hints at the potential
for him to become consumed by ambition
and to lose sight of his Noble
intentions it's also possible that his
fascination with these objects clouded
his judgment causing him to overlook
things like The Potters potentially
needing the cloak to protect themselves
a good example of Dumbledore's cloud of
judgment can be accurately exemplified
by his interaction with marola GA ring
Dumbledore put on the HW Crux ring also
known as marola GA ring because he
believed it contained the resurrection
Stone one of the three Deathly Hallows
he wanted to use the stone to
communicate with and possibly see his
deceased loved ones however Dumbledore
was aware that the ring was also a hawk
RX carrying a piece of alal soul and
would be cursed he was willing to risk
putting on the ring despite the
potential danger because of his
overwhelming desire to reunite with his
deceased family and find solace in their
presence thus his decision to put on the
ring was driven by a mix of curiosity
his thirst for knowledge and his longing
for his lost loved ones despite his good
intentions the choice ultimately had
dire
consequences what do you think did
dumalo deliberately borrow the cloak to
leave The Potters more exposed or was
this simply a case of oversight on
Dumbledore's behalf let me know down in
the comment section below also if you
enjoy the content please like the video
and subscribe to the channel until next
time remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live